you know they used to say when they open
the envelope and the winner is and if
you notice they have changed it too and
the Oscar goes to because God forbid
anyone should think of this as a
competition it might make the trade ads
seem crass and now I'm pleased to
introduce the star of the film gladiator
and a man I like to call a close
personal friend but he asked me not to
Russell Crowe
did I folks heed on on this list of
nominees that people who have thrilled
me astounded me and protected me I have
a great deal of respect for the men and
women to do this job as my privilege to
read the nominations in the category of
editing for almost famous Joe Hudson and
Sark line the Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon
Tim Squires for gladiator Beatrice Kavya
for traffic Steven million the Wonder
Boys Dede Allen and the Oscar goes to
Stephen Maroney for traffic
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Stephen me really
Wow
like to thank my family the Academy USA
films our producers Ed's wick Marshall
Hershkovitz and Laura Beckford my crew
Doug Christ Keith Sadr Norman Walker and
Denise Marquez like to thank Stephen
Gaghan for writing such a beautiful and
emotional script the entire cast and
crew whose outstanding achievement
speaks for itself and Steven Soderbergh
it is a thrill to work with you and it's
a privilege to know you thank you very
much
why I forgot to mention that the
producers this year maybe you saw this
or read this have offered a free TV to
the person who gives the shortest
acceptance speech I just saw Julia
Roberts go whooo